are you someone who's naturally
optimistic when if when you're sick or
when you're fighting something because I
go to humor and very dark humor
um I don't know how you deal with things
um yeah my my humor Shield keeps me okay
um but of course down on the insides you
feel the things and I do it to kind of
deflect and then also make people
not be scared to be around me you know
when when people see me now as a a
disabled person I want them to feel
comfortable that we can laugh about it
um I have a song that I wrote
um called to save you baby hurry down
the chimney tonight I can't cause my
wheelchair won't fit down it
oh my God see you're like me you take
humor with it yeah I mean to be honest
like you know being diagnosed with Ms
last year
um and and what had happened to my body
to my mind to my spirit to my everything
um of course I didn't want to be around
anyone or talk about it but I had to go
to work and um I was not forced to go to
work but I made sure that we finished
the show we had to finish the show that
was like a part of my family Linda
Cardellini and Liz Feldman everyone
there is my family and there's a story
that we needed to finish and I pushed as
hard as I could through that so it was
really incredibly difficult and then I
went to sleep for a few months and then
all of a sudden now I had to come out
again and um be this person that you
know people had seen me as this other
person for the last almost 40 years and
I'm different now and it's incredibly
hard no it's it's uh yeah I don't want
to be the the fish in the fish tank but
you know I'm gonna do my best to just
get through it I suppose
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
I'm going
[Music]